为什么你需要实盘100单训练器
大多数交易新手在认知市场时
往往会陷入两种极端
第一种是觉得市场极其复杂
价格波动完全像是随机的
认为只有庄家才能操控市场
普通人难以获利
第二种则是觉得价格走势清晰可见
认为自己可以轻松抄底逃顶
秦庄获利只在朝夕之间
更有甚者觉得通过交易很快能实现财富自由
阶层括约似乎唾手可得
然而成熟的交易者都知道
这两种认知都存在误区
市场既不是由庄家完全掌控价格
也不是完全随机的
虽然大部分行情难以预测
但其中仍有一些可以识别和理解的规律
真正的交易者任务在于
识别出这些可理解的行情
并通过策略持续博弈实现盈利
这就引出了盈利的关键
成功的交易并不依赖于预测市场的所有波动
而是在那些你看得懂的行情中
通过机械化的交易策略反复操作
积累稳定收益
换句话说
市场中有些因素是无法控制的
而有些则是可以控制的
要成为成功的交易者
首先要学会区分这两者
例如交易者无法控制的因素
包括市场的随机波动
噪音以及政策消息对短期市场的影响
这些外部变化是不可预测的
也难以避免
但与此同时
交易者能掌控的核心在于在哪里开单
每单的仓位止损和止盈点
也就是说
虽然无法控制市场的外部环境
但可以完全掌控自己的交易决策和风险管理
因此在交易中
我们应当放下无法控制因素的纠结
把注意力集中在可以掌握的部分
在这些可控的范围内
精准掌握每一个细节
保持专注
严格执行交易计划
然而很多新手在实际操作中常常忽略了这一点
他们开单逻辑异常随意
早上看价格形态开一单
中午因美联储新闻再开一单
晚上跟随群里的大佬开一单
临睡前再加上一个孕期单
期待一夜翻盘
连亏四世后
没有反思自己是否有交易策略
反而情绪上头骂一句
频繁更换策略的结果是
无法在自己可控的交易逻辑上做到稳定一致
反而让交易失去方向
导致频繁亏损
为了帮助新手克服这些问题
我们设计了这款训练器
培养你对开单止损和止盈的机械化执行能力
直到你能够流畅的自如操作
真正做到知行合一
内心无抗拒
这套系统框架帮助你专注可控的部分
摆脱外部因素的干扰
一个理想的训练结果是
你不再纠结于要不要开单
而是直接思考仓位的大小
到达止盈点时
不会再犹豫是否该赚多一点
而是清楚适合自己的止盈百分比
如果价格没有按预期走势
你会自然接受止损
而不是在各个群里询问价格为什么跌了
或者是否要加仓扛单
最终你不再纠结市场是否被庄家操控
而只关注自己是否能够更加尊重市场
值得再次强调的是
实盘100单训练器
并不是让你盲目依赖指标信号
而是引导你学习并掌握每一个稳定的交易框架
这套框架的逻辑是固定的
不受主观情绪和个人偏好的影响
你的任务是在出现信号后
结合已学过的交易知识
冷静思考
并有效应用到实战中
逐步提升交易的一致性和成功率
为了让大家更好的理解训练器的效果
我在这里分享几个实际操作的案例
并谈谈对价格走势的一些思考
当价格在信号一的时候
我们发现我们开始以损定仓开单
这时候作为交易新手的
你需要通过第一关计算你的风险
然后价格在上涨过程中
我们发现价格从结果来看是击中了止盈三
但是在上涨之前出现了回抽
反倒是让我们止损出局
那么这里又引发两个思考
如果我止损放宽一点
我就能躲过这次无效止损
对不对
被扫损后
我是否应该立刻再次入场
以上是信号
一在固定的框架下
你需要的思考信号
二出现后
我们还是按照逻辑先以损定仓
但是这时候我们发现信号出现的位置
是前高区域
这时候主观的思路还是介入盘面
前高区域开多
感觉不太保险
但是我尊重训练器的信号
继续开单
有意思的事情出现了
价格确实在前高区域回踩
并且非常快速的冲向你的止损位置
这时候你的思路开始变得主观
在某种程度上开始出现预测顶底的苗头
而价格确实下跌了
更是无形中给你的信号
我的判断质量高于训练器
接着随着价格不断冲向你的止损位
你开始思考要不要自动止损
小亏一点
还是说坚持固定的逻辑
你的内心开始矛盾
主观思路与客观策略开始打架
很幸运
这次价格并没有打损
那么接下来我们又发现价格没有到达止盈之前
相比你已经计划好了
到了止盈一我就止盈20%
止盈二
我就止盈30%
止盈三
我全部平仓
结果价格也收增
止盈一结束
这时候你又会思考
分析师说这里是垂线
代表行情即将反转
我这单赚钱了不多
但是20%要不要走人
行情和你的计划再次出现了偏差
你再次陷入矛盾决策循环
当然更值得我们思考的是
当价格到达止盈二的时候
很有可能你预设只因为等你看到价格后
你发现价格又收真了
这时候你会想要不要现在就止盈
还是等价格再次上升后再止盈
信号二引发的最后一个思考
就是价格并没有击中止盈
三到止盈二后开始下跌
那么我应该全部平仓还是上调止损线
等待行情发展
最后信号三出现后
你发现和信号二出现的位置差不多
会不会价格再走一次
信号二差点把我扫损的走势
这是矛盾一说性价格直接击中了紫银三
但是出现了一根非常让人头大的长上影
但是训练器没有做空信号
你会想要不要我脱离训练器框架开个空试试
还好你反应过来了
你在训练
那么你还有最后一个问题
止盈三后
你已经没有仓位
但价格还在继续上涨怎么办
你卖飞了
仅仅是这三个交易信号
我们就已经训练了
以损定仓
接受无效亏损
主观判断行情走势与客观预期差异
差点被扫损的心态变化该如何止盈
每次止盈多少
止盈三后价格继续上涨
那么是否要再次入场
异常引线卖飞整个判断流程中
处理各种矛盾信息的思路
以上这些你会遇到的问题都只是冰山一角
在你赚到第一个100万的路上
你会遇到上百个类似的问题
并且需要你每个问题都有答案
当你看到这里
你已经有点迷惑了
那么我们再来个简单案例
图中出现了八次连对信号
价格走势非常流畅
从研究角度来说
你肯定会计算自己赚了多少钱
但是就像考试中
如果连续八个多选题全部选B
那么你心里会不会犯低估
在进行训练的过程中
这些问题你都会遇到
而训练器提供的固定框架将限制你的思路
迫使动用所学的16期视频的交易知识
你唯一需要做的就是在行情出现后
专注如何根据策略进行有效应对
想要交易做得好的
关键是不断处理类似的这些问题
而这些问题并不是通过一两次练习就能掌握
只有经历了几百次甚至上千次类似情景的训练
你才能真正理解其中的精髓
熟练应对并控制好自己的情绪和心理
最终成功的交易者是通过反复应对这些问题
在实践中累积经验
逐渐能够流畅的操作
稳定的盈利
总的来说
100弹训练器是一个帮助新手逐步上手的工具
它能帮你建立一个基本的教育框架
通过系统化的训练
让你更快地理解市场
提升执行力和纪律性
虽然它不能让你一夜暴富
但他能一步一步的帮你累积经验
最终实现稳定盈利
不仅如此
这款训练器对有一定经验
但想进一步优化策略的交易者来说
也是一个不错的选择
你可以通过它进一步磨练自己的交易技巧
找到适合自己的风格和策略
好了
今天的分享就到这里
如果你觉得实盘100弹训练器对你有帮助
欢迎在视频下方留言讨论
感谢您的观看
这里是百万交易员
祝大家交易顺利
早日找到自己的盈利之道